so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
I've just noticed this was right there
sorry for everyone that's not visually
watching the car you didn't see what I
saw everybody here on YouTube I thought
that was awesome what's up guys I am
doble Thomas whatever you want to call
me this is the dope as usual podcast I'm
here with my co-host Marty O'Neill
what's up brand new Instagram name Marty
made it just in case you think it's fake
no it's Marty made it new Instagram guys
we're here in the dope as usual podcast
I am very excited we're here to talk
about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between today is the solo episode it's
my favorite thing to do my I know the
guests are great
this is my favorite thing to do guys
thank you so much if you are here right
now if you're watching no matter where
you're watching do us a favor drop a
like on the video whatever you're doing
subscribe comment star whatever app
you're watching on we really appreciate
if you're on Spotify shout out to
Spotify once again for partnering with
us leave a five star review it would
help tremendously thank you very much
guys we're gonna get straight into this
rant City we're trying to make it
non-existent until January and we will
tell you why this is going to be a tight
episode I know I said that for almost a
year and a half straight but for real
this time it is Saturday night me and
Mario were like yo let's watch UFC and
then it lined up to where we're filming
right now and USC's playing in Minnesota
wall but we'll catch up on it this is
what's going on this has to be edited in
one day the past couple weeks guys
during holidays it's harder to get
guests during holidays and stuff
because they have families we have a lot
of guests lined up but this one we're
like you know what let's go solo episode
we need to do a catch-up episode let
everybody know what's going on what's
been happening are you ready you know
I'm ready oh yeah yeah oh what do we
have one minute yeah no I know I was
like holding back yeah
okay I'm gonna put the sliders in my
hand already you've been doing good
shout out to YouTube yeah shout out to
YouTube no age restrictions fully
monetizing everything no limited ads
thanks let's go thanks guys like I said
we're gonna keep this
tight I'm not trying to go what was I
talking about so here we go all right
guys thank you so much for being here
this is the dope's usual podcast and
we're about to get started on some epic
wins super dope news the Epic News the
dopest
it's awesome are you guys ready actually
no let's start off let's start off with
the loss
if you guys have been following this
podcast you know me and Marty every week
every Monday three o'clock sometimes it
rarely it's like an hour or two late but
that's like YouTube uploading and stuff
takes too long or the edit crashed rare
that we missed that date we have never
once missed an episode never in our
lives we missed an episode since we
walked in this door ever until last week
the last week guys I'm gonna just break
it down what happened I'm sorry me and
Marty were both not stoked about it at
all
when we decided I think we just need to
wait till Monday I went oh
oh God we missed a week
missing trash day like
I'm a oh God anyway I felt stupid Marty
felt stupid too it sucked but let me
explain to you why not an excuse but let
me explain why and why this happened we
had a certain guest now I could even say
it because I don't want you guys to go
[ __ ] on them we had a certain guest
right lined up
the full rescheduled four times which I
was like you know what it's okay I get
busy I would never reschedule four times
but I get busy too morning of it's 10
o'clock we're supposed to film at 11 and
they hit us up the manager says hey can
we push it to 12. go perfect that's fine
no worries at all you're showing up
great we get here 23 minutes before 12
o'clock manager hits us up I answer this
number I've never seen it and all I hear
is
I'm like oh what he goes hey uh there's
a family emergency he's not gonna be
able to make it and I go oh no worries
man totally cool oh oh okay thanks man
like he thought I was gonna rip into him
I'm like no no worries man it's not your
fault hung up with never in life is that
poor person coming on our show ever
again I've never felt more played in my
entire existence of like we're sitting
here already we were sitting here joints
roll and I went all right Marty Martin
doesn't live close yeah so we lost the
whole day of editing it was actually a
little bit more like it was a little bit
more frustrating because they actually
moved it sooner I was like slated to
start going to the gym that day that's
right that's right I pulled up to the
gym parking lot we were supposed to film
at like one or something yeah and the
opposite and they were like hey can we
bump it up to 12. so I'm like oh good no
I'm first day back at the gym it's fine
I'll just leave yeah so I left and got I
had to come in earlier I mean it takes a
good hour and a half to get here and
then drive back but not even that I left
in New York hours later for five days
for the meet and greet so that's why we
couldn't do that was a real sickening
feeling yeah and I was like wait
no guess and we was like what'd I say
let's do a solo go why Force something
yeah we want to be prepared yeah we
weren't planned we didn't have what we
wanted to talk about
no no so we decided
to just take a take a loss
well I actually kind of it was kind of
nice it was all right it was all right
one day I'm sitting there like
it's three it was nice for me because it
was literally my first day off of a
seven day work schedule in years yeah
yeah oh I get why it was awesome I
didn't have to do anything it was great
but I just thought of the how many
people are at work like this refresh
refresh oh that bummed me out but anyway
we followed right up with the rain uh
phase Rain episode
awesome what a dope thank you for all
the support on that episode too because
that's cool right now that guy's awesome
man thank you guys so much for
supporting
um so I said every single thing we
needed to say about that I'm not going
to keep talking about it let's move on
to the next subject yeah I worked out
for the bus because we came back with a
smash episode Everything feels great yep
yep see no rant City we talked about it
just to go let's move on okay guys very
next thing all right let's talk about it
I went to New York all right it went to
New York again all right this one was
for the um meet and greet for the dopa
shop we're doing meet and greets and all
bunch of States real quick I'm gonna
give you a recap everything was great
everything was fun I found out because I
hate flying I I hate flying and if you
hate flying please listen to me I think
I found the solution
I think I figured it out on the way back
from Chicago on my seat in front of me
there was video games I played video
games for five and a half hours when we
landed I didn't realize where we were
I'm like whoa we're done I've been
playing Plants versus Zombies for five
hours so Rosie bought me his Nintendo
switch I played Tony Hawk and Mario
those all the way there to New York all
the way back didn't even look at the
takeoff didn't look at the think about
turbulence nothing I'm just stuck trying
to beat these damn games and I still
didn't beat the games but the moral of
the story is I figured out flying
distraction distract yourself all right
never would have dawned on me to do that
nope I mean I'm sitting here [ __ ] I just
sit there with my [ __ ] head in my
hands and just I know how much I hate it
everyone around me is asleep and I'm
over here just tweaking on Tony Hawk too
just like the school man I couldn't find
all the bells to wall ride and I think
Jack Black is the voice of the security
guard in
in a Tony Hawk too he's had a few few
words and I heard it went Jack Black I'm
in the plane like what
nobody's awake so I can't like
nothing so uh fast forward it was a
Trippy now that you know Tony Hawk
playing that shot you know what's really
crazy is when I got on Tick Tock and he
goes from your contacts and it popped up
Tony Hawkins from your contacts
that's weird
whoa awesome
yeah it was a chip playing with Tony
Hawk and I played with Tony Hawk the
whole time I'm like no this is only
right that's only right I really wish
you could grind like Rodney Mullen but
it's okay you know what I mean like I
was playing it was dope
um NYC trip uh you guys might have seen
it but I finally guys finally
okay I posted a video earlier somebody
made a video from the second they woke
up at the Chicago meet and greet until
they met me and went home
like gathered their homies how hyped
they were how excited they were talking
about all the stuff they watched the
drive over there them talking about
stuff in the drive gets there I remember
seeing these dudes in the parking lot
looking at me and the thing is like if
that part's in the video I just I happen
to see these dudes in the parking lot
I'm very observant right so I saw and I
and they're like
like they had a whole day they're lying
their weight in line they're getting to
me talk to me drive home home talk about
the day it made me so happy I got Vlogs
huh bro they were so excited and seen
and the way they were saying stuff about
it's me it's weird because it's me so
I'm thinking like this guy talk about
his sounds oh yeah it's You full so I
kept thinking about like is this how
people
think
because that's how I think about certain
people yeah I finally have a fan base
where people care like the way I care
about certain things blew my mind the
reason I said that I just went watch
Adam Sandler live in New York in Long
Island which
Rosie when she found out we're going to
New York she looked up and she told me
like we're going to see Adam say I'm
like shut up no we're not what are you
saying
hey bro I Rob Schneider is great I saw
him he was just seeing we got close we
were close
watching Adam Sandler come out bro and
walk and I went there he is and then I
watched that video today and the guy's
like there he is oh my god that's
literally how I felt and it made me feel
like
I can't wait till I'm 50. hmm that's
gonna be a good time when I had to play
My Hometown Theater do something you
know I was like
watching that and seeing the reaction of
all these people and seeing everyone so
Juiced and they were just as excited as
I was
like
I don't think I bust my phone out a few
times just because I was like I gotta
remember this like I have to have some
physical thing and other than that I
didn't require I just sat there and
watched it
your favorite rapper and your favorite
comedian actor in the same month
pretty soon yeah it's pretty sick and um
I might as well be the only [ __ ]
in that room I was staring just watching
it's like watching the way this fool
talks like watching the control watching
everything it's like
that's
feeling that I'm getting right now it's
like I can't wait till people have that
and then watching these videos I'm like
they do
holy [ __ ] and people tell them like
you're my Adam Sandler I'm like
but seeing him in person man whoa
where did he come out and do like stand
up his old stand-up like he used to do
comedy albums songs and stand up stupid
stuff like goofy stuff
same thing all new material but
it was great dude nice it was great just
watching and like
I've been listening to you is it still
the same dude or is he like oh this is
like an older version of him now I can
tell
did it feel the same same person nice
same guy and looking at somebody worth a
half a billion dollars dressed like a
fool it's like I can't wait I love it
bro
I don't care I just love it I just I
couldn't believe it finally
is the blueprint just look like that's
you you're my favorite person in the
world you're right like and the thing
that kind of he was doing a song and
like picking people out in the crowd I
need a I need a girl blonde hair all
right come on he's like I need a fat guy
with a sense of humor that could take a
joke and I'm like
no I'm not going to raise my hand the
first time I talk to you I want to be on
this table I don't want it to be in the
crowd and then the guy next to me stood
up and he wasn't even fat
and he stood up in Addison did the whole
song and posted it posted him and you
can just see the side of my head I was
like that's me [ __ ] I should have stood
up and took a joke but I was like no
there's gonna be a huge guy that's gonna
make it better foot was like
180 pounds like bro you can run and [ __ ]
like you're not fat uh more the ending
as I was walking out there was an old
man busted down the middle somebody got
in a fight at an Adam Sandler's fan
which is like
you need to reevaluate your life
you can't be finding the Adam Sandler
show that's especially insane and this
time like this is like a anywhere it's
like this happiest Show on Earth it
could be kind of like older people
they're all in their 30s and 40s right
this man was 55 years old fighting some
like 40 year old man bro damn full-grown
men fathers fighting it was funny to see
anyway Adam Sandler's show that was
awesome is Adam Sandler like is he known
as a weed dude
I think behind the scenes because I know
he does smoke weed
mm-hmm yeah I couldn't remember if he
was like one of those dudes that's just
known as like the first weed thing he
did was in hot chick when he was like
you put your weed in here he played the
guy with the dreads and then the next
kind of weed thing I saw was That's my
boy when he's turned around I want to
see my boys smoking we didn't even smoke
a weed with Vanilla Ice
I don't see any other weed [ __ ] coming
out of Adam Sandler's realm I don't
really see much of it but you know motor
is high as hell you're hearing Chris
Farley all the time you're probably high
as hell yeah makes sense
he said if he wasn't yeah even if he
wasn't uh he was hyped and the thing
that made me still he's like yeah I live
in L.A now I'm like hmm do you I'm gonna
see you one day I'm gonna scream out the
window
um that's all I have to say about the
New York ship of that part uh fast
forward all right couple days the meet
and greet went awesome it went great the
only problem was
there was like a booth next to me and I
like completely crowded the room I felt
so bad like the whole room was just
packed with people in line so it kind of
cut off a certain line
we need when we do meet and greets it's
got to be our own thing there's too many
people to be having other it was at an
event yeah it doesn't work it doesn't
work New York people are so friendly and
awesome
I always see the absent on movies but no
there everyone was so nice and dope I
met some some people from the chat also
j-h-i-m I always say his name JH I am
rim met him he's cool this dude named
Colin man out there I met a lot of
people I've met from chats it was pretty
cool
um but then we're going to do a New York
one in February we're gonna go back and
do our own and we're gonna have like
three floors of this building so we're
gonna have
everyone can come damn you know this one
was 21 and over because it was an event
so I kind of limited us to certain
people some people might be 21 next
month and been watching for five years
yeah I don't even matter you know but
New York secret session meet and greet
dopa shop everything went really really
dope and um yeah and that's everything I
meant to say about that Miami oh thank
you thank you this week I will be in
Vegas at MJ bizcon
December 3rd or 4th I will be in Miami
at Miami Ziggy's the Ziggy smoke shop in
Miami doing a full meet and greet
second or third week of January I'll be
in Houston Texas haven't picked the spot
yet Houston Texas for the next meet and
greet right after that three weeks later
we're gonna go back to New York and do a
fat one dude that one you should plan to
come that's the one you should plan to
come with us
um but yeah so yeah dopashop.com we're
we're doing a lot right now they're
rolling right now so much man
um
rosin donut or do you want to start off
with uh oh no it's only right we gotta
all right here we go
here's a little story I'm about to tell
you guys
a couple months ago I did a vlog called
my first Weed grow and it's a machine
called the hey Abby grow box remember
the machine a little machine
that you put a plant in and it grows by
itself so here's the story it was about
four weeks in everything's going good
the guy laying on the couch may or may
not have killed the plant and he's
telling me he didn't which he did
killed it
I came home and it was dead I asked him
to trim it don't speak you don't got a
microphone he can't even back himself up
trust me he murdered my plan
Master grower over there and then
I replanted a couple like two weeks
later after I got the another clone
that's what took so long I was a month
oh a little more than a month in had to
wait another two weeks that's why it's
almost two months late but yeah it was
sad it was sad and Goblin named the
plant himself remember he's like that
plant is now named Nicholas all right
Nick so Nick your plant died but Nick
too is strong your son passed it down
and you're still fine this right here is
our weed weed that we grew in our own
box that was in there you guys saw the
machine you guys saw the plant this is
it the Vlog comes out this week actually
this is Monday Vlog will come out
probably Wednesday or Thursday
here we got a little probably about an
eighth of each of the weed this is our
own wheat smoked on the show let's go
would you kill eat what you kill yes
Marty this is our weed all right there's
not the strain
Midwest Midwest Nick that's what it's
called okay but um the strange like I
think a gelato sure cup mixed with OG so
I don't know what this smells amazing it
does it does smell good very inviting oh
[ __ ]
all right
all right for everyone in the car they
went why'd you say [ __ ] you I dropped my
joint I said [ __ ] you're not [ __ ] to
Marty
oh also I told Marty the other day I'm
like somebody thinks you look like
somebody they know that was a tax
scammer Marty you weren't a tax gamer
right because not as far as I know I pay
my taxes yeah man I just paid my home
taxes I could have bought a [ __ ]
block and buffalo with that [ __ ]
the manscape Platinum performance
package 4.0 it's a top of the line gift
you can give to the man that has it all
deck the halls with a fresh set of dick
and balls this Christmas season manscape
performance package 4.0 the Platinum
package is the ultimate package it has
each best-selling product from
everywhere as an Ultra Premium body wash
two in one shampoo and conditioner also
has the premium deodorant the lawnmower
4.0 body trimmer the weed whacker ear
nose hair trimmers all coming with
Advanced Skin safe Technologies protect
those little Jingle Bells they're also
waterproof they're also coming with the
4 000 watt LED light on them also
remember guys manscape offers shower
products now gels shampoos two in ones
there's so much that they have get
completely stocked up for Christmas guys
it's coming soon once you give your girl
a nice gift this holiday season and come
with the fresh undercarriage for her
needs this Christmas every shower
product is sulfate free vegan and it's
made to not dry you out the good times
don't stop in the shower manscape Scotch
with the crop preserver ball toner the
crop reviver ball deodorant Santa's
gonna be jealous of yourself this
Christmas get 20 off in free shipping
support the podcast manscape.com go to
manscape.com forward slash Yola and
that's 20 off of every single thing you
order and free shipping make sure this
holiday season you're fresh and ready to
go
so sir
do the honors yeah later on let's go
I don't know if I do you have a lighter
on you Erin
throw it but throw it good I know you're
a Rams fan
click it's quick
foreign
if you would have just threaded the news
okay thank you sir okay with my left
hand what a dick
um can't grow can't [ __ ] throw and
grow or throw
girl
just turn into a [ __ ] rap battle oh
I'm sorry also for all the Rams Fans out
there I'm kidding I don't care about
football that much uh he just likes the
ram so when they lose I text him
no words all right ready
for everyone out there
the person I'm making fun of on camera
is Paul Ruben Peewee Herman's son
's dad PeeWee Herman that's his dad look
at him look at his face
look at his outfit he's a model
people hear me small too
thanks Marty
I'm just talking [ __ ]
um here we go lighten these joints up he
was our first first photo shoot ever
first photo shoot in my garage in my old
house
wow I forgot about that
yeah the collar flip-up shirt wow okay
let's get back on track back on track
we're lighting this joints up here we go
right on the next thing huge news
huge ass news you guys [ __ ] ready for
this
man I like that noise
you ready for this right now no not
right now two days ago it happened I got
an email from YouTube you guys know
YouTube Dope is Yola account uh when I
first started uh up to like 700 000 I
was never messed with nobody ever messed
with it I never got restricted never got
deleted nothing
got to 995 000 subscribers the night
before I hit a million got deleted they
deleted my whole Channel with no strikes
no warnings nothing
Just A Yank is yanked me
Marty got it back for me got it back
it's been about a year and a half I've
never been paid by YouTube you guys know
that long beat it into the ground 180
million views almost
billions of billions yeah billions 1.7
billion minutes of watch time at least I
think on the story times
never been paid while being monetized
but never got the money 2.9 mil I should
have got
29 million dollars this is a lot of
money
a shitload of money never got it can't
be salty about it because I'll [ __ ]
explode okay so who cares it's fine
never got a check mark never verified
the biggest we channel on the planet not
very nothing Forbes it's cool Forbes
articles fat History Channel cool [ __ ]
so the other day YouTube emailed me and
said hey
you're a proof of verification give us a
few days and you'll get your check mark
verified first time I've ever been
verified check two hours later verified
guys
the dopa Zola Channel now has the
checkpoint verification I've never had a
[ __ ] check mark on anything dude
tires are turning folks on anything
other [ __ ] tables are turning
awesome literally that's it so when you
see dope as yellow with a check mark
That's me so no more scam accounts on
YouTube you didn't start crying you
didn't get all butt hurt you went and
started the podcast then you went and
you started Adventures YOLO started
laying down heavy duty content on that
[ __ ] while maintaining and even putting
out more content on the dopa's girl
Channel for free just assuming one day
they're gonna [ __ ]
start treating you fairly and what
happened
10 years I started dobiziola next week
will be 10 years to the day all right
it took whatever 10 years and 52 weeks
is minus a week 52 weeks is a year okay
so 519 weeks it took right 52 weeks of
the year yeah 10 years
519 books basically oh no for two times
ten five
529 weeks it took to get verification
wow
that's probably wrong a lot of people
wouldn't have been able to run that
marathon with no end in sight with no
end inside with no money either all
money and no money out yeah I know but
yo they verified me on top of that a
week and a half ago what happened Marty
on the dopa Zola Channel
and then monetized
I am now monetized the YouTube the
dopasiola YouTube channel is now
monetized on the partner program I
showed Marty there's money in my bank
account on the YouTube bank account
like the next time they pay out I'm
gonna get paid by YouTube for the first
time
it's gonna go down in the history books
of [ __ ] perseverance and bro
just I mean Jesus Christ you don't
understand like what it feels like to
just get those doors slammed in your
face when you're trying you're putting
your all forward it got to the point
where I went of course it got [ __ ]
yeah it got to the point where I didn't
I was surprised if something went good
like yeah of course bro but I'm gonna
keep smiling I'm not gonna go oh yeah of
course it's me I never did that I went
yeah I've never been more impressed by
somebody the other night you got deleted
and that next morning I didn't know what
to expect that next morning I remember
I'm like
I should just text Rosie and even see if
he even slept last night or see if he
even feels like talking like we gotta
regroup I knew it was time to huddle up
and regroup and that was a horrible
[ __ ] feeling
yeah I was fine I was pissed but I was
fine it was right before the podcast
started
[Laughter]
they deleted my big Instagram the 299
000 yeah two nights before the podcast
dropped remember that yeah that was cool
anyway
um verified monetized Guys YouTube is on
my side
[ __ ] out of here you my last story time
is fully monetized and getting paid
who would have thought who would have
thought that that would ever happen I
was just making them to make them
because I knew I would never get paid
and here I mean it's not a lot of money
but because the content's explicit so
they don't they don't put a lot of it's
not fully monetized but some more
some are green which is crazy that's the
point it's about perseverance and it's
like this if that's what you do
you know like it's not it's a situation
where I mean look at Rogan like we
always say like they didn't [ __ ] with
Rogan like this he was the we dude
freely on his [ __ ] no problem Oh Joey he
has all these dudes like we just don't
want the extra treatment and no it's
starting to yeah I just want to be
treated fairly not give me any special
[ __ ] just go hey you're a normal guy Let
It Go
that's all also this tastes good oh yeah
I like it so I know we got distracted
because this was the happy returns this
is our weed which is the craziest thing
I'm like a proud father right now yep me
too it's like a cigar thank you yeah see
I tripped it I chopped it watered this I
want to trim it next time I've never
actually trimmed I've never done
anything to smoke I know a lot of people
that would let you dream for free do
that right now they would be happy like
oh
[Music]
you like it no you can take some nugs
you're not happy they would be I'm just
talking about our hey Abby okay never
mind so if you want to get in the dream
room I got I can call somebody right now
peas they give you 100 200 a pound which
is terrible so if you want it here we go
guys sorry
um right on to the next thing without
whoo What time are we at
28 minutes in all right guys let's talk
about this we talked about it briefly
uh one two three four Marty wants you
want you
do that number four
huge news oh yeah yeah we've already
kind of touched on this one we we did
slightly like this much yeah but not in
a Solo episode yeah no this is uh
this is probably one of the biggest
things ever at least for me because this
is really personal for me and we're
talking about the TED Talk
this is really personal for me because
it's been like part of my dream in you
know inadvertently from the night the
story I told you about when I met my
Aunt for the first time that ended up
living in my dream house who I would
then go out and hang out with in the
[ __ ] dream mansion yeah the night I
met her she's like you know what you
should listen to Ted Talks they'd be
really good for you to listen to because
it's all about like you know different
ways of thinking and ideas and [ __ ] she
just like and she reiterated it a few
times and then when I like was keeping
in contact with her I was telling her
like I'm watching these TED Talks all
this [ __ ] so it was just I don't know
it's just been like really relevant to
me ever since
and now uh and now yeah so again shout
out to Waldo for linking it up while I
was coming in a huge success right now
they're like they're looking they're
like a blueprint right now why are you
always says the west coast to us a
million dollars worth of the East Coast
us they just got re-upped it with a huge
deal huge deal bar stool they're balling
out of control ah come on bro real quick
they decided 20 million dollar deal with
the incentives to possibly get to a
hundred on their podcast this fool just
got out of prison Greece like years ago
he's a 20 years in prison came out with
the knowledge Gilly's over there Goofy
and funny as hell YouTube yeah cultural
advisor at YouTube they just signed the
deal for their show Marty
come on man when you see people that are
like oh yeah they're really putting in
work and they actually got paid
come on not to mention Gilly I was
watching Gilly on Smack DVD back in
[ __ ] 2000 2000 and he was a rapper
like he was a [ __ ]
oh cool and look how it goes that's how
it goes sometimes guys it's just like 20
years ago at work now it's like now we
hit his [ __ ] he was given advice on
Instagram that's what million dollars a
game was he was answering his DMs
that's how it started yeah oh and then
wallow got out and they were just doing
Instagram
yeah then it became now it's like the
biggest rap show with drink Champs and
[ __ ] I love drink champs yeah anyway
shout out to wallow cuz
yeah we connected before they started
the podcast and
cup and touch and then he'd linked me
with the dude from Ted Talk got started
to get to know him Corey shout out and
uh
then we booked the probably one of the
most beautiful badass venues in all of
La the Dolby Theater [ __ ]
theater and the Heart of Hollywood right
on the Walk of Fame January 6th that
[ __ ] date is locked in an
official tickets are available if you
haven't got it
that was kind of already put out a
little bit we dripped that out a little
bit Yeah on social media locked in uh
but it's going to be an official
[ __ ] dope as usual event Thomas
and me one of the first times ever a Duo
takes the stage at a TED Talk Hollywood
January 6 [ __ ] get tickets January 6 20
23 [ __ ] Mario hit the cricket
accident oh [ __ ]
oh let's go it's okay it's okay it's
okay but me and Marty are speaking Ted
Talk speakers I remember the first time
I publicly spoke I had to read my
[ __ ] thing in fifth grade I remember
I blacked out and went everybody clap
and went oh I've read it I don't
remember reading it now we're about to
be in front of 4 200 people talking and
the thing is it's like
it's not that long ago now we're doing
business advice to corporate people
that's crazy yeah I really wasn't those
porches were not that long ago you were
chilling in the ghetto not that long ago
Marty
it's powerful [ __ ] man that's what I
love about this story I was unraveling
this [ __ ] is crazy how it's happening
so we're gonna we're gonna do the show
as a Duo they don't normally do that but
we're gonna Crush that [ __ ] yeah there's
the only option so anyway the theme of
the show is the money never stops what
would you do if the money all
disappeared like which is [ __ ] all
the [ __ ] that we've been talking about
basically this episode thus far
so that's what it is how would you how
would you still function if you with
your brand as your fan base as a Creator
if you had no money to do and both of us
were broke as [ __ ] all the time so it's
a perfect topic I can tell you how to
survive without money and make content
uh let me let me let me give you a
little story like my thing is the talks
are 18 minutes that's not enough time we
gotta really a lot of them are shorter
than that too the ones I was watching
eight but 18 minutes bro nine minutes
nine minutes basically that's like
before that's like the nice guy clock
yeah that's a nice guy clock except
we're gonna be doing this
yeah
for everyone in the car I was doing
teacher talk
and I mean I'm gonna have a joint in my
pocket just so I can say that I had weed
in my pocket when I gave the speech and
I'm gonna smoke it right after you get
off stage yeah I can't wait it's my to
me the fact that you know I deal with a
lot of my career has been based on
working with live performers
it takes a lot of people the whole their
whole career and they never get to reach
a venue like the [ __ ] Dolby Theater
people will be on the road for years
killing themselves at Hell clubs and
different shitholes around the [ __ ]
country just trying to earn the right to
take a stage in a theater period any
theater that's not some club and the
fact that we're going out here and have
this opportunity and like we like we
said last time the main Narrative of it
was if you had to leave Earth tomorrow
what message do you want to leave behind
the people as it intertwines with your
story and the conflict and the theme of
the show and the resolutions and tips
hacks for people that want to be
successful so this is like a stamp it's
like put that [ __ ] out there and just
let it will be on YouTube too that's the
other thing it's going to be on TED Talk
YouTube channel for everybody that can't
make it it was crazy our names
Ted Talk Channel yeah ted.com
oh yeah go ted.com our bios are on there
as speakers coming up [ __ ] weird man
it is weird I gotta be honest when I
when you sent me the thing and I clicked
the language our names are on the
speaker list so Ted is if you guys don't
know ideas worth sharing this is like a
global
a global yeah Global not even a company
it's just it's different topics and they
go all around the world and these huge
events and they have people that are
like experts and their craft come on and
explore these different themes ideas
worth sharing
so I'm excited man you're you you do
your thing is it weird that someone can
literally physically call you an expert
in your craft isn't that [ __ ] weird
because you know you can Crush [ __ ] you
know you can do [ __ ] when someone goes
no you might be one of the best people
doing it like
oh my God that's weird that's weird it's
weird because when people like it's my
favorite you eat too rare am I cool like
y'all you're my favorite person in the
world like
you didn't make the best content in the
world
oh my God thank you it's just to me it's
like
go back to Buffalo I go back to Merced
like do you think this will work you
think I could do something with this I'm
not I'm not like something in your hands
but like your music and this and this
and I'm like these videos I could do
something I remember when I said this
could be something and it's like wow man
10 years later yeah
it's weird it's definitely weird it's
surreal to be going through the ship so
I'm just trying to like
I'm just trying to give it everything I
have that's why I've just been sinking
into my routine and like if ever you're
gonna get after it now [ __ ] stop being
such a lazy [ __ ] and get after it yep
it's been hard why are you going yeah so
I'm back activated on my program and it
feels really good because it clears out
my mind Marty makes three shifts in the
morning goes to the gym he's just like
all his programs bro
he hits burpees in front of his daughter
I wrote down my schedule for the first
time ever and I'm sticking to it and it
just I need that Mark Wahlberg schedule
over here 5 30 awake like [ __ ] you man I
can't get to sleep before one my brain
will not shut off I wish I could I gotta
be asleep by a 10 at the latest
you know what it is for me it's the fear
of missing out as a kid bedtime nine
o'clock
funny shit's on at 9 30. and I feel like
I'm gonna miss out what the [ __ ] am I
gonna miss out on that's what my brain
does but stay awake fool stay awake you
can always go to sleep later that's what
my brain does it [ __ ] bugs me
um yeah I told you too ever since Rosie
had a surgery I was like yo Rosie leave
me alone guy I got [ __ ] to do when we're
gonna work we'll work because he's on
like 24 7 and then lately I just been
man
I'm late I got I slept in for the first
time in 10 years
so it's like this is not good and when
people sleep at my phone I see you wake
up at 10. [ __ ] went to bed at
seven [ __ ] you
so it's like I'm finally getting late
like we're used to going to sleep and I
don't like it I got [ __ ] to do I know
bored of being lazy I don't like it dude
I've been lazy for two and a half months
I film on Wednesdays I film on this day
I film on this day other than that I'm
gonna go chill
I don't know what I was thinking I told
you the other day like I woke up feeling
like what am I doing man Rosie's feeling
better I'm up it's not all work though
it's just it's like it's like life yes
self-care like go go here go this do
this do this if I don't have those hours
what am I supposed to do so go to the
chiropractor because your back hurts
yeah but I gotta film this gotta be off
in two days I have to do this good
Chiropractic you can wait
[ __ ] like that that's how my brain works
like don't who cared you see me I'm like
I'm not gonna eat until I'm done filming
I know it's 9 30 at night but like oh I
don't eat before we do weed videos I
feel all not on my [ __ ] but the podcast
we're sitting here we're hanging out
we're talking it's different but I just
feel like I need to be on it more that's
all that's really all it's about but
tedx like you were saying you got to go
hard Ted Talk guys January 6. Marty and
I we're gonna I told you we're gonna
walk up go like this and then hop on one
foot like an old like hip-hop dance crew
we're just doing full breakdowns
we're gonna say everything out
let off a big ass caught a smoke like
LeBron yeah I'm gonna wear a headband
and I'm a spit water like Triple H
the right the whole front crowd get my
spit
see this is rant City all right here we
go Ted Talk guys huge news Marty and I
gonna be speaking in front of adults
yeah all right we got the link on uh
Instagram link on dope as usual oh you
can go get tickets if you there's a
crowd there's an audience if you guys
want to be there that's what he meant by
the link people are flying out yeah
which is crazy I gotta kill people I'm
flying out to see Ted Talk guys it's
right in the right and like if you're
gonna come to Hollywood this is where
it's at like it's right in the center of
the shed so thank you guys my dad's
coming dude no really I'll make sure
I'll make sure to be there
he's funny
I told him I'm like yeah I'll get your
tickets like Thomas I won't I will make
it oh
everybody recognizes like that's like a
stamp now they've I explained what it
was you had no idea what it was but I'm
like yeah you should cup like I'm gonna
be speaking I was [ __ ] weird but I
won't speak a speech with Marty oh [ __ ]
yeah I'll be there I'm like all right
Dad you let me know and I got you mm-hmm
yeah should be interesting it's gonna be
fun though I'm not I'm just because that
is writing that's like the week we're
really gonna be starting off season
three Uncle meets Studio too yes we're
leaving
it's time level up as seen on Forbes as
seen on TED talk give me a [ __ ] check
mark Instagram first point man come on
put more notifications or clarifications
of Publications do you need sorry I'm
just bitching at this point sorry
um
hey man it's gonna be cool thank you
guys thank you guys this whole message
all these Vibes everything we're feeling
right now we're gonna go out and give
that to the world that's positive piece
of [ __ ] supportive of your [ __ ]
homies and [ __ ] ones that make great
decisions and do good [ __ ] or throw home
throw if you want to hit your friends in
the face with ashtrays and peculiar
plants totally go for it nobody's gonna
be mad at it I thought he was looking at
me that's why I said sorry my [ __ ]
friends just house cat in it over here
laying across three couches
um with Lil Wayne
all right guys sorry rants that's that's
rant City you know it's bad ranting when
I'm saying [ __ ] that's not even on
camera even the people here can't see
what I'm talking about I'm sorry guys
take it back also
let's go hey how did I not see this
joint guys
how many episodes and I saw this today I
was like oh joy I'm dumb all right thank
you guys so much for that hey Abby weed
burned Caucasian
wow clear
it burned good take half that jar you
know what leave me like two nugs you
take the rest
or we could do as a podcast jar you can
just leave it there and we roll and we
smoke joints up to you
um straight on to the next thing guys
really positive news let's get let's get
productive fired my printers after nine
years working with them almost eight
years I should say fired them wanna know
why they gave me my biggest order ever I
washed one and it cracked and I went
guys you guys print for the NBA you
print for a thrasher and you're [ __ ]
me
sorry you wouldn't do this at Thrasher
is it the seventh time you've done this
but they always fix it but this time I
was just [ __ ] pissed for some reason
like I felt play which items were these
oh my sure
my shirt it's just [ __ ] hot it's been
so long I don't even [ __ ] remember
the new homies oh my God that was in
like August June July yeah yeah I'm
getting samples from another place right
now it's so many years in and I'm still
looking for new manufacturers all the
time because people I wish I can go hey
me take a piece off and grow another you
and go work at the [ __ ] print shop
like perfect
it's gonna get done right because I give
a [ __ ] for some reason I feel like yo I
pay you in full I paid you in full when
you only wanted to deposit because I
said nah get it done
and you give me [ __ ] I'm so done
what was it like eight months ago like
nine months ago hey man I've been firing
the [ __ ] out of people remember also I
got this new thing you're not gonna work
right you're [ __ ] done I'm finding
somebody that will cause usually I'm
like I don't want to hurt your feelings
that's the point I'm at right now and I
won't get into it but
I fired him all right that's why there's
a lot of push tree [ __ ] has been slow
there's not too many new designs also
got like a house worth of backpacks
and all the logos are wrong
backpacks are perfect
and the logo is has the head blending
into the arm
on every [ __ ] bag that was the same
two days and when I found out my shirts
reflective
I put down a Merced house to get my new
collection for back to school
it's a semester's over
I'm so like uh anyway I'm not trying to
complain I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm just
trying to let you guys know what's going
on push trees we have so much stuff
coming out did all these photo shoots
all the photo shoots and then I washed
it cracked so I'm like bro how many more
bands I put in to say hey use this in
four months yeah not now like it's not
even that like I'm sold out of [ __ ] plus
trees is just kind of like doing this
right now it's a steady not doing [ __ ]
because I don't have that much stuff to
sell of course we get sales it's just
like I'm not selling [ __ ] truck
clothes like I'm supposed to be it's
really bugging me yeah um but yeah you
should have dropped [ __ ] three
collections since since then
I know
what I'm trying to say is look it's been
years we've been doing all this [ __ ]
successfully I still [ __ ] up I still put
my trust into things that shouldn't be
and look where I'm at it's been nine
years I'm starting fresh I might as well
be a new clothing company with a
warehouse because I have no gear so for
me to you it's not all about wins this
is losses I'm showing you guys right now
how many episodes is this and I'm still
talking about [ __ ] mess-ups so
everybody out there don't be afraid to
show that you also [ __ ] up you also
don't do everything right and sometimes
things don't go right we're never going
to sugarcoat [ __ ] you know I mean like
we're not gonna sit here and go in a
clothing company
never [ __ ] up before you know I'm like
whoa what would that be like the show
you come to to watch perfect
[ __ ] which don't exist
no that's another show that show is
called scripted comedian podcast you get
what you sign up for with this [ __ ] my
problems that's right up front before
the accomplishments it is yeah because
there's always problems before
accomplishments that's how you figure
out that you can get it done
got an Iverson shirt on for everybody
driving all right guys so that's that's
my topic wow didn't even
no red city today I love this okay done
cleaning you're like a gymnast going
from Pole to pull
even at that I'm just gonna leave it at
that
chemical makes great high quality
Japanese steel kitchen knives using
traditional techniques from Japan
kamikoto knives only use steel from the
mills in Japan the techniques in the
craftsmanship on this took generations
to make and they're still doing it the
exact same way 19 step verification for
each night each knife is inspected fully
by hand with a lifetime guarantee each
knife it comes in a beautiful heavy duty
Ashwood box to make sure it's stored
safely the Box alone makes this a great
gift as soon as you hand this to
somebody it looks and feels expensive
high quality and heavy duty kamikoto has
an array of different knives and they
also have this set this dope set right
here this is a three-piece set the
vegetable knife is seven inches long
eight and a half inch slicing knife and
the utility knife right here this little
guy all the blades no matter what are
coming with a high quality satin finish
give it a nice lustery feel single bevel
Edge is what makes them stand apart and
you get cuts that you wouldn't get from
your average knife you can maintain the
edge of your Blaze
if you want a chemical to sharpening wet
Stones Cami Coto knives are worldwide
they're used by Michelin star chefs
everywhere on top of all the special
offers they have going right now on
their Black Friday discounts go to
kamikoto.com dope get an extra 50 USD
off your order kamikoto.com to get your
knife sets again go to kamikodo.com
forward slash dope that's our discount
code for the dope as usual podcast and
that's going to get you 50 additional
dollars off
MJ bizcon I'll see you in uh next week
this week actually because come up
Monday I'll be in Vegas if you're out
there say what up come by the dopest
shop Booth it's the one with this
[ __ ] face on it
um speaking of Vegas thank you guys for
tagging the [ __ ] Diaz brothers oh
yeah yeah Nate saw that [ __ ] in the
story I know I saw him see it I still
don't see it I was I went through his
[ __ ] bedroom windows
damn near the biggest podcast of all
time as far as I'm concerned 209 fool
what come through and smoke a joint with
somebody from your [ __ ] area
we could talk about how shitty it is
come on thank you guys I know your
cousins literally they were my sound
Engineers come on man come get high with
us and talk about the 209 and like the
landmarks and crackheads
the landmarks are the crackheads does
that mean oh the Taco Bell hobo he got
shot by the [ __ ] cops A new cop let's
just leave it at that we're not gonna
get flagged
sleep Jesus
um yeah yeah Diaz brothers that would be
stupid I like imagining like I'm just
sitting there they're living their lives
and all of a sudden those notifications
oh these two high-ass fools
the [ __ ] [ __ ] is this
but hey we can all play bloody knuckles
come hang out while just [ __ ] sock
each other's hands every couple of
minutes I would not want to fight them I
don't want to fight anybody just because
it's like dude
if you punch me and hurt my teeth I'm
gonna kill you if you mess up this I'm
gonna murder you and also if I hit you
and you fall what if you die I go to
prison this is good night let's all just
smoke a joy you know what I went through
for this [ __ ] Invisalign yeah yeah if
you know when I had to get sawed for
this
I'm gonna kill you I didn't murder
um but no for real that would be an epic
epic epic episode they've never really
done a podcast that's the thing they
ain't gonna do a [ __ ] podcast
together we're damn near from the same
place bro come on
not to mention Nick Diaz is a cannabis
Pioneer martyr oh I've given them both
weed before I have it on camera they
came to my booth when I used to do push
juice cannabis company for those couple
months and the people [ __ ] it off yeah
um which by the way oh real quick real
quick by the way
within the next two months post trees
cannabis company is a full up and
running spot our [ __ ]
massive buildings are done shout out to
my homie I don't even say his name
you know who you are me and my homie
winning on this business together we are
legally in the Cannabis industry now
push trees cannabis Co all right
wait for the fire that comes out we're
working with these working with certain
geneticists and farmers
Boutique wheatum is coming I can't wait
to people that don't like me get my
reading offspired but [ __ ] that guy
that's what I want
because people like you are going to
like it anyway people that hate you are
going to look for anything to hate you
then this has been a really long time
just been a very two years in the making
and finally it just got signed like five
days ago damn building's done buildings
Acres but no I mean like you have the
whole experience of like the dopest you
know how to roll [ __ ] out now oh yeah
this is different though man the weed
Market's different like
you me like for the dopa shop we can
have a product to us in a month and a
half that's gonna take three months
every time and it might not even be that
good if that yeah you'll be like there's
an outcome so you got to pick your team
it's coming anyway sorry I gave Nate
Diaz and Nick Diaz when they came to our
booth once I [ __ ] gave them both
wheat so they're they're awesome super
dope
um
that was Vegas oh we ranted a little bit
I'm trying okay oh yeah yeah yeah oh
before we get on to this next dopa shop
topic uh Donuts the donuts sure yeah
let's see all right shout out to my
homie Nico over at [ __ ] Kush Clinic
dude
mutant genetics that's what this is
called this is brand oh [ __ ] so this is
donuts ready this is what a donut is let
me explain this to you guys this is a
joint
all right OG's been doing this for years
John hash has been doing this for years
and they just it's now it's a trend and
that people make companies about it
right this is what you do you uh lay
your paper out you cover it with weed I
go about two grams then you get your
rosin and you make it like a snake if
you get Ross and Marty and you like roll
it like Play-Doh if it's not too sticky
you can roll like Play-Doh will come out
to a little snake yeah you place that
[ __ ] right in the middle of your joint
of the weed and then you form the weed
over it and that keeps the rosin to the
middle so what happens the rod is in the
middle of the joint once it catches the
rosin the rosin Burns faster than the
weed it'll start melting melting melting
melting and cause a hole straight
through yeah donut gotcha that's what
the donut is so this is my homies brand
suck yeah he gave me these like hey
Smoke them out all right smoke them uh
today and try them out so you have these
things look expensive
moonbow from archic uh Bank 1.3 grams a
week
0.3 grams of rosin in the middle and the
rosin is orange limeade from ha hash
it's like solid as a [ __ ] rock Yep
this is what I do let me see it real
quick because I know you don't smoke
pre-rolls too often I like to tweak
everything I don't care if you rolled it
perfect I gotta make sure there's no
hard spots because those hard spots will
make it to where the joint the nugs fall
off
even though they're not nugs it's but we
will stick together when it's good
[ __ ] weed yeah if you have trash you
don't you don't do this yeah you know
but when good whether it's good weed you
just gotta not want to [ __ ] it up glass
tips anyway I got the
um Bubble Gum poppers and grape Dodge
that's what the stranger called they got
their own [ __ ] like I've never heard of
these these are all um these strains are
all from bougie farmers and when I say
bougie not in a bad way I mean Farmers
that care and will rather like yo I
don't want 10 pounds if it's like okay
I'd rather have five a fire that's the
one we done that's we don't want to
smoke so we'll light these up and I'll
show you how to light this up right now
but let's move on to this topic since
rant city is non-existent right now
we're trying to get on this Ted talk
[ __ ] I'm trying to go over here like hey
corporate guy Instagram here's a clear
thought hey
levels of stuff influencer marketing
like I need to like get on my [ __ ] my
mom smoke meth acid like I don't know
what we're going to talk about exception
yes conception
conceptualize I don't know how to talk
here we go I just don't want to say
[ __ ] dude twice it's okay I don't
think it matters it's all good I'm
saying like I want to get it down to
where I'm not just spurting Michael
Scott [ __ ] improv comedy conversation
yeah I need to be honest when I get
fired up too I just start oh I know
Marty's going to be doing a lot of this
[ __ ] my he's gonna poke the
motherfucker's throat right in front of
the [ __ ] stage I already know I can't
wait I'm excited dude I'm excited I
don't know what to I don't know what we
should wear because I know we shouldn't
look like [ __ ] bummy kids but also
I'm not gonna be like oh you went like
shopping and bought all new clothes like
yeah I did I just don't want to look
like that I don't know what to look like
I honestly I just want to wear what I
wear yeah I think that's how it is
[ __ ] Vans with the laces wearing
suits and [ __ ] for it I don't think that
you just wear what you want I'm just
gonna wear suit and vans dirty ass old
fans
um okay so let's light this up real
quick so then get in this topic light it
not like yeah like from the very front
like this party all right
okay here we go
this is how I like the joints you want
it to be even because there's rosin in
it and then look at stop do this one
now do it again that just burns that
[ __ ] paper layer because they always
put the paper layer on the top
and then I do it again
and once you do that paper's gone right
now go
don't put the flame to it put the flame
in front and you inhale in the air
should bring the flame
because if not you'll hit the whole
bottom turn it black it's annoying
see and hit it again
even
hey perfect oh these you gotta smoke
like this too Marty keep them up
because if not the Rod's gonna drip out
so keep them up yeah and be careful
because if there's a lot it might come
through so just piece gotcha all right
this [ __ ] is fancy let's go there's a
couple of distinguished gentlemen over
here you're gonna taste it you'll taste
it right when the rosin hits
we'll see your face all right here we go
next piece of information guys the
dopashop.com you know our brand we
dropped something this week it's called
the hhc hella high club dopest
subscription box every month
um you pay a fee you get this box to
your door certain we'll go over
everything obviously well you know we
will [ __ ] it you get it gets it's
cheaper all the items come out a week
and that everything in that box comes
out two weeks before anybody else in the
[ __ ] Earth can get it only people
that smoke that are you part of the club
and John and I to approve this [ __ ] then
everyone else is allowed to buy it weeks
later that and in each box is a golden
ticket and this month's golden ticket is
a trip for two to Vegas we're just gonna
do it every month it might not be a
Vegas trip next time I might be like a
[ __ ] best buy shopping spree I don't
know we're just trying to make it fun so
we're people are just buying our [ __ ]
and by the way oh my God I [ __ ] won
so this week or this month uh the golden
ticket is a trip or two to Vegas and me
and John are going to pop up on whoever
wins
do your thing we're not going to eat up
your vacation time but it's going to pop
up for a couple hours hang out smoke I
mean if you want maybe you don't want to
hang out with us I don't know but that's
what we're gonna do and uh
I'm not gonna say everything but
it is selling like straight hard drugs
holy [ __ ] Jesus Christ people are hyped
man limited it's limited to only 1500
people yeah it's 1500 people per month
so you get first dibs if you were a
subscriber the month before so you can
keep your run going forever yeah because
you get on the unlimited discount no
matter how much you order as long as
you're active as long as you're active
forever
if you're buying for all your homies buy
the box and just buy for all your homies
and charge them regularly I'm not saying
how to scam your friends but if I was in
college I would be taking advantage of
that
and we got the rosin up this [ __ ] is
delish this is like this is a different
type of experience this is like my homie
from uh Nico from Kush clean email Nico
uh Kush Clinic um they're a delivery
service out here in La they have the
Exotics the whole the Exotics bro not
all those deliveries I mean not all the
dispensers carry with the [ __ ] they
carry which is awesome
I gotta go there yeah I'll uh I mean
you're good so this description box on
the dopashop.com crazy I'm not gonna
talk I never talk about money new
products in there too yes all new
products but products that's never been
on anything liquid Diamond pen two gram
disposables guys two grams
I can't wait to try them okay I got yeah
I got every one of them for you so
like I said don't talk about numbers and
[ __ ] but we almost hit our first the
first day we dropped we we had a number
we crushed it we almost hit that first
day drop again numbers
never thought it would happen again
because you know it was such a big drop
like dude this is the middle of the week
oh [ __ ] people are so excited dude I'm
so I love how creative you guys are
getting with how you're rolling out this
[ __ ] and just keep like this dope [ __ ]
back to the community I'm just like
making it such high quality [ __ ] I've
learned so much just watching
you guys execute all this [ __ ] it's
weird dude because it's just hi John me
and then Claudio's professional ass it
was input like this would be good this
would be good all right cool let's add
this add this Claudio's our corporate
side John's the bougie side and I'm like
well no John's weed and bougie but I'm
more of like
this has to be tasting perfect well you
know John is too no everyone's equal we
all put in bro like I mean I'm not
saying we're all don't put in but we all
like have our input that just rolls it
really works like everybody just click
click click works perfect I I don't know
how to explain it but yeah next month
will be a year that we're in business
pretty crazy December 17th shout out to
you guys because I've been technically
officially
In Cahoots with the dope it's not his
past couple months but yeah full-time
editor bad yeah oh everything edited any
single thing you see oh Marty
um but yeah dope a subscription box
super super dope um all right all right
here we go I haven't seen any of the
stuff you wrote so what's that mean
power slap
allegedly Dana White's starting a
professional open-handed striking League
you mean like a slap contest I've seen
that online where they have the uh the
slap and they hold the bar they slap a
Chevy he's starting a league for brain
damage
apparently he already has a league for
that but I mean this is just no that's
that's that's that's uh skills this one
you could be a drunk fat [ __ ] yeah
that's true you could just be a domestic
violence abuser and win this league
it's true you could yeah yeah so that's
cool so that's cool
I've seen the dudes versus chicks one
oh I'm sanctioned that I haven't even
heard I saw I've seen some YouTube ones
where they just they hold like the stick
on the you know the things that people
do like the bars in the Olympics where
it's like a little horse
it's like what the [ __ ] they call it
[ __ ] where they put their legs over and
over and over on the on the bar on the
Olympics there's two handles on that
thing and they go yeah yeah they have
one of those you hold it and you smack
the [ __ ] out of somebody with your other
hand and that keeps you from falling
yeah and it keeps you from moving too
far and there's two people behind each
contestant so when they get knocked
asleep they don't fall
I I also saw a little people League
little people uh slapping league so that
guy's doing away fairly little he's just
a short dude over here picking on little
guys the guy that won was like five nine
five foot flat you're not a little
person at five foot hey man he was no he
was murdering these three foot tall
dudes dude that wasn't that wasn't yeah
also being that little you're a tough
guy
all the experiences
you never want everybody beat you up
oh you threw your whole life now you get
an equal shotgun like a different guy
you're high come here that's messed up
man Dana White really just goes for it
Jesus Christ laughing League
Jesus Christ
oh that there was like co-ed slappers go
to YouTube Bro YouTube has everything I
wait for the shiv contest when we wait
till that comes out take one to the to
the rib
what are people going to think of Knox
Jesus Christ savity
um so the slap League UFC president unit
was right Dana White
you just copied that out oh okay you see
President okay all right Marty what's
that what's that note huh
I was just commenting on I put a video
out on Instagram
we might not want to get flagged for
this I'm just I'll tiptoe around this
the uh okay the Kanye Direction This was
just a huge coincidence
all right we talked about it out here
then you put the video up yeah oh gee
explain the entire thing to us on his
episode
about Adidas yeah he did yeah that were
rose right before and then we all talked
about it I don't think we talked about
it I think it was while we were it was
before we started filming maybe and then
you talked about it on your Instagram
yeah and then the Kanye West thing
happened guys you know how bad it is
when I had to ask a week later go what
happened to Kanye West yeah that's
[ __ ] stupid because when I see tablet
when I see a news you know what I do I
go yeah not of I don't care where's the
stuff I want to see thank you don't care
I know people like you're not educated
like am I supposed to worry about the
rapper
and what the rapper says bro I'm sorry
dude I don't care go be mad go do your
thing damn you're doing everything away
damn what did he say and that's when I
looked in and I go oh
hey man don't be pushing it just live
your life that's how I feel like so you
rock the boat full doing here see Donut
oh yeah
get that [ __ ]
but anyway I put out a little history
lesson there it is yeah you see that
that's why it's called a donut yeah we
saw you put out the history lesson and
then what days I only did that because I
was legitimately just doing like
fun facts about logos research to make a
[ __ ] Instagram post and I found out
the founders of Adidas and uh may or may
not have been fascists yeah I mean the
Adidas and uh what's it called Puma were
you know founded in the 40s in Germany
like there's a whole interesting story
about these two brothers Volkswagen also
yeah all these companies I'm sure you
know if you were there you were in the
[ __ ] but it's just people I don't think
really realize that so I made a video
like Adidas the dude Adolf dassler
that's where Adidas came from Addie Das
people think all day I dream about
soccer no I was homeboy Adolf over here
in Germany
and you know what I mean when World War
II was over they let Adidas live you can
read about this like the American
soldiers let the they said this is some
fresh ass kicks don't shoot him but
here's the crazy part
uh uh Americans
African-American Olympic American uh
Jackie Owens was wearing the Adidas in
the Olympics so they told the Americans
like we're Adidas we're like literally
that's why they didn't burn down the
Adidas Factory and it remains today and
it went off to become This Global thing
the two brothers split apart the one
started Puma
the dude's wife it's already it's in if
you start reading these articles about
it it's super interesting okay but they
were the power before the internet bro
just cut your hair yeah for real start a
new life yeah unless somebody who's
dying a polio and they need to come to
your town for medicine and I'm pretty
sure you're gonna get away with it the
[ __ ] was just crazy because I put out
this video just because I didn't know
that like that it was founded that's
where its roots were you said some of it
OG started agreeing and talk yeah you
want to go oh you're not a historian
anything you got to say and then you
kept saying wait OG you're not kidding
because 99 OG talked on the phone
OG talked to my phone he called me at
midnight FaceTime I was like okay we
always do
but I I need you to see
oh [ __ ] that was a gangster ass
screenshot look it look he's [ __ ]
faded oh my God he's always shirtless
with the up angle smoke Amy that's
everything every time that's that is OG
and then he sent me this picture of 16
with Mindy look at him oh [ __ ] look at
OG young bro he looks just like his son
you guys see that look let's go
shirtless
no tattoo OG picture wow bro
oh my God
I was supposed to go to dinner with that
food Saturday damn
there you go it's night time Marty well
you know he didn't call me either so
we're fine
I forgot it's Saturday Adidas I
I put that out there everybody was just
astonished first of all I don't even
talk on [ __ ] like that so uh I put it
out there just because it was
interesting and people were all
astonished I ended up just deleting it
just because I didn't like those kind of
Vibes just even on my page but then a
few days later it's this whole
completely related controversy with the
thing that's like bringing Kanye West
down to me I don't give a [ __ ] about
like his whole to me he stole the Jay-Z
producer from the blueprint like I had
Kanye West I'm good single mailed to my
house back in the day he's still that
guy that was future Hell episode with
freeway Jesus walks with him and mo
staff and [ __ ] Chappelle exactly the
devil's trouble break me down
like that's I don't know it was just
interesting but it was a crazy
coincidence a couple days later this
whole anti-semitic situation comes down
and like
okay media you check your sources [ __ ]
oh
we got the whole song stuck in my head
so bad so when that came out that out
his first album was such a [ __ ]
classic it's it's sad to me almost like
where everything is at now because it
was so pure you such you don't get that
artist producer combo like him I mean
barely ever really like almost never
that's true for hip-hop he came out from
behind the scenes quick you know like
Anthony Avila burned me that CD at jdk
CD and uh
uh mg eight ball what was it yeah
MJG thank you so I saw this and that's
what reminded me of a look at MG
MJG that's how I was thinking if you
bring me that album the eight ball MJG
Jadakiss and Kanye West's uh debut album
and he burned I have the CD still they
have my handwriting on them Kanye West
has my with red marker on the purple
DVDs used to burn that's when I almost
died when my grandpa my entire family
like o'doyle's from [ __ ] Billy
Madison yeah when we almost died I was
listening to the Kanye West album when
it happened it was a song with him and
Ludacris like Breathe In Breathe as I
was playing when I went
it was an experience
and then now he's like all in trouble
so that's pretty much that's pretty much
all if you could take away from any of
this podcast all these other podcasts
you know Kanye West needs to do this you
know I'm with Kanye West man I [ __ ]
and us oh so that man's in trouble
with the joint oh he's in trouble what'd
he say did he apologize
oh [ __ ] also um freedom is the beach say
whatever you want I don't give a [ __ ]
don't listen to him if you don't like
this stuff he has to say
like people that say stuff on shows I
just change it like oh that was
offensive
it's [ __ ] up yeah
you know what perfect example I was
driving today and somebody's taking
forever so I was like dude bro you look
at your phone I went and as I went they
laid on their horn and didn't let go of
it and drove past me and I went
I have a joint
there's no reason in the world
I don't care
because they're a piece of me said get
out and punch this motherfucker's window
real quick and and see what he has to
say about that like he the way he was
coming up with me was like what the [ __ ]
you gonna do fool that's how I felt like
[ __ ] you and I went
you know what this is a good song
and I'm like maturity
I like it that was it those those are
the things like if you don't like
something continue I didn't like that
guy honking at me I could have gotten to
a situation I didn't want to be in that
random person could have took you off
track the rest of your [ __ ] thank you
or that day pissed me off I know I
thought of you know what good thing I
just didn't do it because I imagined
myself punching it and busting my
[ __ ] my whole wrist I was like What
if I broke my wrist and called Mario
like yo I can't film today we missed
another week
so I'm like thinking of all the
consequences of things like you know
what
I like this car a lot I'm gonna keep
driving it that's all I thought like you
know what this car is awesome
kept going I was like yeah it's okay
it's okay because there's a few times I
have hopped out in L.A I've jumped out
of my car about five times but uh only
because I felt played I had a guy to uh
cut me off twice and I stopped and I'm
just and he went back in the land I went
oh chill this guy's weird got back in my
Lane
cut my ass off right in front of OG spot
before I even worked there
I remember his haircut stupid ass shirt
remember everything
and he cuts back over I'm like oh my God
and we just happened to pull up next to
each other I look at him he does this
did that when he did this I was like
I just lost I don't know what it was
it's the most like offensive thing that
if he would have busted a gun out I
would have felt better than this
the way his face went yeah I was like
I'm gonna grab that [ __ ] little hair
you got and I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out
of you and I chased that man for six
blocks damn oh the thing is when I chase
somebody I only get this I get this
close to their bumper I'm not gonna
really hit your car but I just want I'm
a good driver so I want to push them and
scare them so they have to hit the
corner without looking so if a car is
coming they have to slam in the brakes
and they might hit another car then I'm
gonna go like this
and I'm Gonna Leave not a person like a
parked car that's not my real intention
I don't really want to hurt people but
that's like this here I want to put in
you like and like do the next line I'm
gonna take a left to leave I don't care
I just need you to not feel like you can
do that [ __ ] and I couldn't I couldn't
get him to stop anywhere so this is why
I keep a lot of lighters in the car
because when you hit a motherfucker's
window with your lighter and it explodes
it is so scary hmm lighter's popping
scary so I'll keep lighters in my car
and I bust them on Fool's Windows when
they won't get out their car and and
um it makes a spark it looks great damn
scares and pieces go everywhere
it scares the [ __ ] out a few crackhead
lighters pop easy I've only done it
twice all right I don't think I'm a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] the only time I
hop out my car is when you risk my
[ __ ] life
and you don't care or you do this
[ __ ] to me and only when you're a
dude at least my size are bigger I'm
never gonna pop an old man or
not gonna happen this white dude that
did that [ __ ] to me was [ __ ] big but
I for some reason I knew like he was
nervous but I don't know I take
moral story is if you ever see me
chasing a [ __ ] through L.A no
it's Justified okay they deserved it I
have such a not bad temper that if it
gets to that point you better [ __ ]
try as fast as you can away because my
car is faster than yours that's all I'm
gonna say I will follow somebody and
just keep driving just to put the fear
in their heart of three minutes of
getting away from this dude doing this
in the review and then I just drive off
like most of the time just smoking in my
car and I feel offended so I just I know
I'll never do I got a stock someone's
gonna shoot my ass but I gotta stop I
also shoot them so you know what I mean
like it goes both ways take it from me
sir
sorry I'm all hyped up thinking about
people being so rude people rude to me
every day in traffic it is I don't get
it
I don't understand why I'm gonna just be
nice can I let you in
who's letting you in you flip me off
yeah I don't get it man I just need I
just wish you could paintballs weren't
assault paintball guns because I would
just light a motherfucker's window up
and when they rolled I'm like don't do
that
when you roll your window down all that
paints in your window seal forever too
by the way
yeah oh I didn't tell you I wouldn't get
food and somebody blocked me in so bad
parked so close to my car I could not
get into my car
and I went to every business there
politely and asked is anybody's truck
back there because I was just really
high I was like you know what
I I'm no need to get mad let me just go
talk to everybody I went and talked to
everybody in the restaurant
nobody talked to everyone by the pizza
spot nobody talked to the I was just
like you know what I got time to come
and give a [ __ ] excuse me there's a
truck back there's that happen to be
yours that's how I talk yeah yeah I'm
[ __ ] polite
and the lady's like oh no I think it's
the guy that works across the street he
parks there all the time I go oh and
thing is I was at the end there was no
more parking spot next to me so I parked
over my line just so I would
have there's two feet yeah full parked
so close I just tried real quick Marty
to squeeze in to see like possible I'm
[ __ ] fat I am not monster fat and I
couldn't I barely got in I went oh
the door only opened like this enough
for the for the inside of your armrest
to like come out and win and when I get
out I scraped my whole tired greased my
entire pant leg and I just like looked
to the sky and went I have to do
something this is so bad and so I just
key this man's car on this door panel
and I I felt better while I was climbing
my fat ass through my [ __ ] center
console over my seat and I went you know
what
that key mark You're Gonna remember the
car was destroyed it was dented
everywhere I just felt that I had to do
something that I guarantee you the fool
did not know that I keep I went [ __ ] you
I was like God
it was a nice car I would have done it
but I felt like it's a work truck I
gotta do something because I feel so I
felt so [ __ ] played so anyway that's
what gets me upset and yeah I just said
that on the podcast I don't give a [ __ ]
Thomas Keith I might be lying who knows
you're not gonna like open up the Ben's
door into his [ __ ] so that's good that's
exactly the way he did it it was like
bro and I waited like 15 minutes I went
to every single [ __ ] place like I did
the right thing man I did the right
[ __ ] thing and still was like
and when I saw the grease across my
pants I went
truck with a [ __ ] like a cab on the
top that didn't match it like a like an
old work truck it was all dented and
scratched with [ __ ] grease everywhere
it didn't mess the car up I just had to
do it for principal sorry that's rancidy
that's what happened to me the other day
really pissed me off sorry everybody's
like damn Thomas I didn't think I had to
do that when I am April lost our car
keys and then he's someone's car no no
when I had to go
stop me if I told you this already it
was like the day after our wedding and
she left
she left the keys to our 300 at the
little bar that we had been at after the
wedding
so I went back the next day to try to
find the keys okay for the 300C and the
[ __ ] alarm started going off
uh because we couldn't find the keys
they weren't there so I had to get AAA
to come and tow it and AAA there was
like two cars blocking it in and they
tried to like they're gonna like pull it
out of the spot and the alarm started
going off so then I had to go it was a
full packed bar with active volleyball
games going on in the back and I had to
go to each person hey is that yeah
that's my car out there beeping is that
your car next to it the BMW and I said
no okay cool to every single oh that's
your car out there [ __ ] peeping every
single [ __ ] person until there
evidently it wasn't anybody's [ __ ]
car because he had to just rip the
[ __ ] 300C with a chain out of the
position and onto the [ __ ] bed and
we're just getting started because now
okay we come back home to my mom's house
knock one I don't think I ever told I
don't know if I told you this this was
the day after we got married
and we were like
sad because we thought we didn't realize
we were going to be in the red and the
red so bad after our wedding we talking
yeah deep in the red he thought [ __ ]
The Goodfellas was gonna happen hey yeah
yeah I brought Pepsi
it doesn't [ __ ] work like that
and uh
yeah they so we he like backed it into
my mom's driveway and we had to leave
the door open because if we close the
door the alarm would start going off
again so we like just laughed the
[ __ ] door open like what are you
gonna do at this point we gotta figure
out how to get another key
go up to bed lay down as soon as I lay
down
they came and [ __ ] repoed that thing
same night
Repo Man Came that [ __ ] was a month past
due for a month they didn't contact you
oh man I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened they couldn't let you know I've
been a month I'm sure they'd probably
call us we weren't gonna manage and [ __ ]
back then but uh that very night they
came and repoed that [ __ ] that's
incredible that was [ __ ] horrible you
gotta take it away I was alone anyway
the yeah it went yeah what that's like
being in the shower naked at school in
the fall chip your teeth and at the end
somebody in contacts of us when you just
get married and you have a [ __ ] car
that doesn't feel good are you at your
mom's house and [ __ ] living well that's
a [ __ ] baller life what are you
talking about man that's straight
Seinfeld [ __ ] come on yeah it doesn't
happen like that often it's a good story
now it's worth it my mom was like
it's [ __ ] up because my dad died I
didn't get any insurance money but in
that moment my mom gave me enough of the
insurance money to get the car out of
the [ __ ] impound oh that was like I
felt cool about that and then we got
300C back and you [ __ ] kept it and
then your dad her dad crashed it when
you guys moved out here yeah oh my God
that was devastating that almost [ __ ]
ruined us but it was probably a week or
two after we first got to Cali and he
drove that [ __ ] out here congrats and
blew the engine up in the Rocky
Mountains and then we had to rescue him
and April's friend that he was with get
them from the Rocky Mountains with 300
here after we mind you when we landed in
Cali after we drove out here we were
[ __ ] broke it took all of our money
just to get the Airbnb get all our [ __ ]
out here like we were just even we had
to find jobs and then he blew out the
engine on our car so now we have like
regardless we only had like two months
to find a place to live find jobs
um so it was really [ __ ] up having to
put a brand new engine into a 300C at
that time too uh but here we are yeah
and now you're getting paid to talk
about it yeah so did it pay it paid off
yeah hey depending on how much money you
make today hey man you might have that
that might have broke even
it was so [ __ ] stressful because we
couldn't get the check engine light off
I literally almost fought the dude at
the mechanic shop because it was getting
so heated and he was acting like I was
being the [ __ ] uh you know not smart
one in the equation but I'm literally
mean eight nine ten eleven times
bringing it back and forth not able to
get the check engine light off after we
had a new engine put in it so we
couldn't get it registered I'm driving
it without plates on it and [ __ ] what
yeah it was horrible
until I [ __ ] had a [ __ ] meltdown
and they finally [ __ ] figured it out
and yeah then we got rid of that one and
got another 300. I gotta be honest too
every time I feel like I imagine you
younger getting mad at somebody I feel
like you're there and then you just
freestyle
I feel like rapping ass Marty like you
don't even know I feel like you could
have got a lot more done if you were
just like being a dick in the middle
just started flowing on people they
would just be like hit with I'm [ __ ]
entranced in this man and then like
April I see why you married him and you
win everything for free
you know in retrospection I was just
talking out of my ass I got to be honest
but I didn't think you're gonna go yeah
you know nah don't agree with me I was
kidding I could damn near I am a warrior
Smith
honestly when I think about you I always
think about you doing this [ __ ]
well the videos I see
she was a menace
yeah
all right
oh man okay sorry mad off topic here we
go it's okay though we're keeping it a
little bit tight today oh is this a
regular giant this is regular weed nice
I mean fire as well yeah but it's bubble
gum pop this was this was delightful
this was like I am this was like some a
lot of [ __ ] yeah that was real that was
like tasted great
real nice light when pre-rolls are done
right
what more could you want you don't gotta
roll this [ __ ] oh man thank you I love
this this is the only time I smoke
drawings
um we talked about it earlier too USC uh
281 we talked about it yes a little bit
it's happening right now we're missing
it's something that's on the wall which
is awesome all right what's it say new
States voting for weed Maryland
and Missouri Missouri yeah
you figure I would know that you know
you think I would know it's not even big
news anymore it's just like news
[ __ ]
it's bad
I should start paying it you know what
I'll start paying attention more I'll
tell you guys that I'll start paying
attention I know that [ __ ] I was [ __ ]
looking for [ __ ] I'm saying like I'm
sure it popped up yeah I don't pay
attention that's cool those like I mean
Missouri that's like a deep south state
to me like they don't I like when I see
like Oklahoma and
Oklahoma's the Duke California for 2014
right now it's a trap City out there
right now my homies are out there
um so congratulations for smoking
recreational weed Maryland and Missouri
that's [ __ ] tight now they can go to
the store boom now you can go to the
store and get you eat and not have to
worry about getting in trouble which is
cool every State's happy it's gonna
happen is it Missouri like your state
that you use as your reference like no
there's some kids sitting in Missouri
you can't get anywhere kid in Kansas or
Missouri yeah literally it's that I say
Montana a lot yeah because there is and
one kid came to the meet and greets like
I'm that kid from Montana because he was
he literally came from Montana I was
like wow what do you do out there
nothing like well Montana must be the
[ __ ] and hella dope because nobody talks
about it I think they want to keep it
under wraps nobody wants to go to
Montana it could be probably the dopest
place ever
um all right here we go [ __ ] we're doing
a good job here we go get into the
social media talk Marty put this in here
buying blue check mark verifications on
Twitter just happened go
I pulled the tweet from our friend
[ __ ] iron cheek
on Twitter just to kind of sum up this
whole thing because I don't really know
you're bigger on Twitter than I am I
noticed Goblin went and got this check
mark I want to get your thoughts on this
from Iron cheek on Twitter after much
consideration everyone on Twitter can go
[ __ ] yourself iron Chic is an old man
now he's an older man
it's still [ __ ] awesome still
crushing it iron Chic is an old wrestler
from the WWF before it was WWE iron
cheek is awesome and his Twitter is
insane reference my shirt last episode
yes it's she's it's so cool
any global warming go [ __ ] yourself hey
you're personally invited tonight to go
sit by the fire and go [ __ ] yourself he
always ends it we talked about this like
maybe an episode yeah episode one of the
season is the Rolex episode was it yeah
[ __ ] okay never mind yeah yeah I just
watched it oh okay well there it is Iron
Sheik is the man his Twitter's insane so
Twitter Elon Musk bought it the that yes
you guys know about this already because
you pay attention to Earth
I only knew because I saw it on Twitter
did he really buy it
I didn't know that
I don't know I don't watch it allegedly
alleged yeah so you can buy your blue
check mark now on Twitter I'm not gonna
buy that
I'm it loses all values this is all
value it was all value you can buy the
[ __ ] Instagram one it's just not so
clear but I can't I try to buy this like
[ __ ] 12 times from different people
that do that because all they say like
give me all your verifications and I
give them everything go they always come
back every time I try to buy my check
mark on any platform they always go you
have enough publication I go I know that
that's why I'm paying you fool they
don't won't give it to me I have more
than enough I have every all bases
covered now with Ted Talk
all bases and then a home run covered
and you better [ __ ] give up that
check bro because that's ridiculous
shout out to YouTube first off for
giving me the [ __ ] check mark which
is very cool and on the podcast and on
the podcast and the adventures of the
old Channel and you Spotify gave Marty a
verified check mark on Spotify so
buying it's kind of like kind of loses
its value I think because I think when
people see a blue check mark they have
to look and go oh somebody DM you the
blue check mark this must be real
doesn't matter anymore you don't have to
be real I don't care about the coolness
it's the real oh verified because I have
hundreds of fake accounts yes why would
is this like good for Goblin though
because you know it's his but can
somebody else just be God make a name
Goblin and and put a check I think
that's not fair if that's his he's no
one should be able to take his thing
yeah but that's what I'm afraid of like
what if somebody gets the name Yola and
[ __ ] check marks and everybody thinks
I'm fake now that's not fair the
opposite of what it's the opposite dude
because look
there's a hundred fake accounts of mine
right now active on Instagram that sell
weed they won't delete them for some
reason
if I can get a check mark on Instagram
people will finally stop saying is this
a real account yeah how many people ask
me if this is the real account it gets
deleted every [ __ ] three weeks so you
don't know who's a real account like
Hash House somebody had like 80 000
followers on some page and made their
account say Hash House the real Hash
House and it has followers so people
started [ __ ] DM them to buy [ __ ] and
[ __ ] John hasn't had an Instagram for
three months and there's like six
[ __ ] accounts of The Hash House Hash
House with his logos everything he posts
listen to everything everything the
conning people because they won't give a
check mark to people like that which is
crazy how are you not going to give a
check mark to people that are active
real companies it's crazy to me you
gotta it stops people from scamming and
if that's the whole point of social
media is to be real and active will make
me want to make you use your [ __ ]
platform and not look at people with my
face saying they're me selling packs I
report them they don't even get deleted
but I get deleted for nothing so I'm
actually getting the negativity here but
that's what I feel about the check mark
is it lets people know
you know what I mean I could trust that
account because it's the chat it's the
verified one so that's that's the only
thing I didn't like about that
that's it guys but uh
yeah you can buy a check mark now guy
for guys for eight dollars a month which
I think is cool for businesses
it helps but what if somebody
Joe's Coffee Shop three you know what if
they want to get a check mark too you
know what I'm saying Marty it's just
I don't know I think if you have the
publication you should be able to apply
and get it successfully like we should
all but it's okay anyway
um that's what I was we were talking
about the notes for Twitter you're
allowed to do that now which is crazy
and uh yeah that's pretty awesome what
the [ __ ]
oh crypto I was like what what's the
worst crash damn Marty sorry um we're
about an hour and a half in we want to
end this on some something to learn
let's take something away from the
podcast today maybe even just kind of a
Prelude to next podcast oh oh oh okay
crypto crashed all right it's it's it
kind of Tanked it's still there people
still believe in it crypto went down the
drain a little bit the first time I ever
really got schooled and know what it's
about was the first time Eric Khan ever
came on the show right I have a tweet
from from Mr aircon Right Here what's it
say
the normies were right about the whole
time man crypto is [ __ ] I'm gonna keep
my money in a mattress somewhere
that's what he said
to Hermes yeah I was one of them I was
like hey man I don't know about crypto
it's kind of scary it it could come back
it could be great financially I don't
know but
that's the thing we're going to lead it
off with is crypto's crashing we don't
know much about it I would like to know
more and that can lead we've never done
this and that can lead into next week's
episode which is the return of Eric Khan
let's go air is coming back there you go
I like that we've never done a next oh
it's accidental it was good though all
right yeah Eric's coming back guys he's
gonna be on the show if you haven't seen
it Pine Park after dark Pine Park is
owned uh created by hex optic gaming
hack has been on the show uh Eric's now
part owner of Pine Park along with
secret sesh I believe and they have a
podcast called Pine Park after dark it's
Tim from Secret sesh Eric Khan they have
their own podcast go check it out I was
recently well we were on the show about
four months ago and then I did an
episode about two weeks ago three weeks
ago go check it out we did an episode
with them on their podcast and yeah
Eric's gonna come back on
and we did hexes well same uh Channel
yeah awesome channels three times four
times damn near damn [ __ ] it feels like
it I don't even know I'm so high when
we're over there it's the same yeah we'd
walk in we get high [ __ ] I can't
remember how many times I've been
they're gonna be on those guys they're
cool [ __ ] um
but yeah shout out to [ __ ] optic
gaming hacks Pine Park uh yeah so
crypto's awesome so if you got a
question about that should travel
question for Eric Khan and these
[ __ ] comments
the man right now in the comments if you
think you have a good question for Eric
Khan drop it in this week's comments
this episode not in the live chat if
you're in the live chat on the side
don't do that in the comments below like
in the actual episode drop a comment
what do you want to ask Eric Khan he'll
be here next week guys to talk about
some stuff talk about his life and we
can find out what's going on with crypto
because I didn't know crypto was down
until I asked because that's the
ethernet doing
Theory
[Laughter]
you think that coin is the is the core
they put in their computers the Internet
yeah close
and they're related you need one for the
other there you go
damn Marty
I don't know [ __ ] all right so there we
go you guys genuinely saw it right
now.com sign up for tickets see this is
why rant City nothing to happen so for
everyone out the ethernet like I can't
be saying that [ __ ] in Ted Talk I gotta
get seasoned with the technology
somewhat I can't just talk about packs
um
or maybe I can I don't [ __ ] care it's
got any this far yeah okay I don't care
here we go guys this is the dope as
usual podcast this is the first time
we've ever kept it tight went from topic
to topic we're at an hour and 30 full
podcast we did huh hour 34 minutes we
said hour 30 that's the closest we've
ever [ __ ] done all right that's the
best time we've ever done ever this is
the shortest solo podcast of all the
book
[Music]
that was hard
God baby won't you come on the show bro
come on the show cause we may or may not
have got a light
a light yes from Benny we don't no we
did get a yes
we've got multiple answers from Benny so
we're coming this comedy's coming I got
my Parkside Tails also also
Ashley Larry's coming on the show let's
go I'm committed to the character okay
that's got Bella's amazing bad ashy
everywhere we got Darnell Rollins coming
on the show next month also guys it's
gonna be awesome hilarious ass comedian
and
my uh high school re-watching friend
from the Chappelle show actually Larry
I'm very excited we've done that listen
he's so legendary to me he's so little
dirty to me go upstairs and put on some
lotion you coach this put on some lotion
Charlie Murphy oh we've got rappers
right now in the air getting booked on
the show oh bro um
I've been really really thinking about
all right like this is a once in a
lifetime type of [ __ ] that doesn't even
make sense that you have the opportunity
to be a part of so
there's a lot of big bookings I can't
even we're like I can't even know what's
going to happen between now and the end
of the year let alone next year bro the
show is really exciting we can't even
say the names because one name is too
legendary to not say the other or the
other or the other
even though I can't even say it I can't
even say it because it's like
we don't want to promise you guys
something that's not going to happen
soon
already like season threes
looking real good guys we did it yeah
yeah there you go we did it we did it
we're on the
we made a goal we set it out we set by
season three you want to be in the big
leagues and that's what it says
definitely it any one of the names I'm
thinking that you're thinking right now
any one of these people sitting across
from us right here Legendary game
changer oh and Ratchet man coming
through with some crazy guests coming up
soon too oh I don't even want to mention
that [ __ ]
that's the younger generations and
people they look up to that we're look
we're talking about that's the younger
generation whoa that's my favorite
artist of all time these fools are
coming up I'm [ __ ] hyped people just
people are finally looking at the show
and going okay we trust you guys because
usually it's remember like we can't just
have two potted ass kids
hey man we talk about stuff do stuff
prepare
we are prepared we're prepared what's
that Ted Talk hits it's gonna be sick
it's gonna be cool we might have our
first Professor on the show after that
one no no no no so things open up doors
I mean looking wallow it does no it
truly does guys and it's very odd and
every [ __ ] out there even if
you're not from the [ __ ] ghetto in
your poor every fool out there wants to
do [ __ ] that hasn't done it already
please look at it as this fool never
thought he'd be doing this you know I
haven't been
just going with it and working and
working
not being a piece of [ __ ] not being
scared and there you go and not being
scared but most of all don't [ __ ] people
over to get where you need to get
because you will get there if it's meant
to be and you're genuinely true hard
working it's gonna [ __ ] happen
there's so many people out there that
just went thank you
someone you need that because [ __ ] we
all need that [ __ ] so hopefully this is
the episode you reference when you
[ __ ] see one of us in person like it
was this one because that happened when
I was in New York like this [ __ ]
podcast you know more you talk about
this this and this it's just got my
distribution license I'm doing this I
just got the shop
[ __ ] yeah I actually have that guy's
weed it's like Petro or something it's
like a little can it's not the with my
house but no it's at the it's in the
warehouse right here
um crazy dude Marty made it on Instagram
and the subscribers chart we were
talking about the show today it's so
sick every day basically we're in there
talking the dudes in the subscribers
chat are posting themselves up at work
with the little flexes and [ __ ] and it's
just like I remember those days so
vividly and they count all those little
days that seem meaningless as long as
your mind is even if you don't know what
your Finish Line is even if you just
know that your Finish Line is somewhere
other than where you're at right now
like even those hours you're in there
those are all little bricks in the wall
they count and you just when you get out
of there back on your mission even when
you're in there you're on your mission
but you're you're making sure life is
being handled you got your [ __ ] together
because as a this whole podcast the
whole theme of it might take 10 20 years
man I mean look at [ __ ] look at Gilly
now they're on top of the world 100
million dollar deals and [ __ ] he was out
there hustling mixtapes use [ __ ] 18
16 probably and [ __ ] like
just we want to highlight all that and
bring it out because when you're in it
and there's no way there's no
light at the end of that tunnel that you
can see you just got to know that it is
there even if you can't see it
you keep pushing forward to it and be a
good person and I mean all that type of
[ __ ] so it's right there we go it's
there yeah you know like you did with
YouTube like we're gonna get through
this yes I always say one day one day it
won't be like this I always said it one
day they won't not [ __ ] with me I've
been saying that for
the whole thing one knows one day it'll
be different [ __ ] if not [ __ ] it
yeah it's believing in yourself and just
pushing forward with what's in front of
you because even once you get to a
certain level that doesn't mean you
don't still gotta go up against [ __ ]
constantly persevere through [ __ ] keep
pushing through [ __ ] but it's just like
once you cross over into that level of
actually having some success at least
then it's like
like I was listening to David goggin's
book again and he calls it uh he's like
even uh when we me and my mom were flat
broke we had nothing she always made
sure we had cookies in our cookie jar
and he's like now
anytime I get a moral Victory even on
things that don't matter that's a little
cookie I put in my cookie jar so when
I'm out there and I'm suffering you talk
he puts himself Through Torture with
this [ __ ]
he's like when I'm out there suffering I
just go back and think about all my
little cookies in the cookie jar all
those little wins I pull from when I
need them because nobody can ever take
those cookies from me I like that yeah
something tangible to little wins him
passing exams him losing a hundred
pounds and you know uh he had to he had
to run 100 mile race on three days
notice type of [ __ ] without training him
losing 110 pounds in three months type
like be every all those little wins that
nobody knows about like you pull from
like we were saying the other episode
like I'm making my [ __ ] bed in the
morning doing this and I'm looking and
go good exactly the little wins bro
that's the way I didn't because we
always had to take off and went [ __ ] he
said the exact same thing in the book
he's like you don't start a fire with a
big ass log you start a fire with
kindling you need a bunch of little
things to kind of get the fire going and
then you put the logs like that yeah to
get the fire going you can't just get
one big win you can't just do one big
luck oh David Coggins man this book is
so good dude and uh his second book the
follow-up to it is coming out December
6th I've just pre-registered for that
[ __ ] never finished I mean uh this year
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah oh it's November I am
I'm burnt I decided man he's looking
like he's just the power of podcasting
look at David Goggins he went on Rogan
one
one
time
it's different though when a person he's
like a furious Styles yeah you listen to
a person thank you he's a leader you you
he when you hear someone speak
and it's not just like okay you guys
talking it's different when you hear
someone it resonates automatically he
goes you're doing something I don't
think I could ever do and he's saying I
was fat as [ __ ] I just laid like I was
you ha like the way his brain is is like
the way we talk about business and how
to like work and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
is the physical like I really look up to
that fool because I always say that guy
was a fat [ __ ] before look at him run a
hundred mile race
not an animal that was running out uh
rant City can't hurt me go get the book
okay Rosie listens to uh oh yeah he's
from Buffalo too that's crazy as hell
yeah also uh last thing before we leave
I'm big movie person I'm very into
movies I always recognize people you
know I'm like oh that's full from that
oh you can't really get one by me
without me going I know what that
person's from where are you from oh I
got it boom because I always get it 99
of the time
I watch Life hundreds of times hundreds
of times never did I know Rick James was
in life I didn't realize he's Spanky
Johnson
I didn't know that that was [ __ ] Rick
James
Spanky Johnson's in life remember Spanky
Johnson when he's about to dunk Martin
Lawrence in the waters oh you didn't pay
up he's like I need my fingers Spanky I
need my fingers to make money I'm gonna
Bank tell her I start my new jobs
Frankie that's [ __ ] Rick James bro
how did I not see it I told my mom
because I was losing my mind she goes
Thomas you didn't know that was Rick
James you know I have seen this before
that's crazy he looks almost like
Terrence Howard thank you he does look
like Terrence Howard right there he does
look like Terrence Howard in uh that
[ __ ] pit movie hustling Hustle and
Flow thank you I watched that movie with
Joe Fisher first time I really uh smoked
out of a big ass bubbler in Santa Cruz
on his brother's couch and let us
layover I woke up the movie was over and
me and Joe had weed all over we never
finished it one of my best memories sure
it was a classic
whoop that
I was just thinking of like
all these hookers like by rapping and
saying like there's some great movie
dude I love it so much
um Rick James
crazy I had no that didn't really
registered
yo I watched it hundreds of times
that's crazy Buffalo native that's why I
brought it up anyway rant City to the
max we Robles out of here 10 minutes ago
look how fast 10 minutes goes by yeah
sorry guys yeah outros are our outros
are 10 minutes and six topics so it's
okay anything else uh thank you guys
this is amazing I hope you just feed off
this energy till next week we're coming
back and keep it pushing and keep this
thing moving forward till the end of the
year and then season three start and
we're moving to Malcolm media's building
our new set get ready guys thank you so
much for being here from Marty from me
thank you guys this has been the dope as
usual podcast excuse me we're here to
talk about life drugs problems
accomplishments everything in between
leave a like on the channel leave a like
wherever you're at tell a homie that
this show that you watch uh they should
watch and if they like it they like it
if they don't
give it some time it's not for everyone
yeah it's not for everybody that was the
slogan but it's not for everybody it's
okay I get people on the on the comments
like yeah this show sucked but it's okay
bro I don't like Frasier it's fine I
like the show some people like Frasier
yeah some people do
it's on TV yeah I met somebody the other
day my homie taller owns part of secret
session like he like Frasier because I
love doing
you liked Frasier why I'm gonna hold
debate anyway thank you guys so much for
being here Frasier sucks appreciate you
guys so much uh have a dope ass day for
Marty and I
all right switch left oh man
oh yeah we did switch it up actually I
was just talking oh you need the lighter
I gave him the only lighter the whole
time
[Music]